هو هذا اعلان همم ولكن السؤال يتعلق
بالاداره الامريكيه هل ستنفذ اي خطوه
سياسيه ضاغط على اسرائيل من اجل هذا
الاعلان هي كانت قد اعلنت مثلا عند فوز
بايدن انها ستعيد مثلا فتح القنصليه
الامريكيه التي كانت مفتوحه منذ القرن
التاسع عشر وكانت تخدم الفلسطينيين في
القدس الشرقيه حتى الان لم تقدم على هذه
الخطوه قالت انها ستعيد فتح السفاره
الفلسطينيه في او المكتب التمثيل
الفلسطيني في واشنطن لم تقدم على ذلك احنا
نرى ان كل اعلانات الاداره الامريكيه اللي
احنا يعني نقول عنها جيده ولكن اين
التنفيذ ليس اليوم انما منذ ان بدا عملها
لذلك نعتقد انه فيما يتعلق باعلان ان كان
الرئيس او وزير الخارجيه همم الامريكي ان
هو يرفض الاستيطان هذا رد ربما للعلاقات
العامله لان هذه الحكومه ماضيه في تنفيذ
سياستها ان كان سابقا وان كان اليوم